tu as déjà fait les prestations boîte de
nuit avec toi
[Rires]
pourquoi personne ne respecte merde j'ai
animateur comment tu aimes faire chier
je mets le combat tu prenais
environ entre 2000 et 3000 €. d'accord
pour 2h de boîte de nuit pour 2h et moi
je calculais pas mon temps donc 2h et je
restais jusqu'à la ferme d'accord
tu faisais quoi moi des booking des
ménages ouais alors moi quand j'étais
vraiment au top ça c'est dégradé mais
j'étais à 4000 euros de nuit pour faire
un booking mais c'est pas les gens qui
me plaisent c'est le patron de la boîte
oui on se rend compte que c'est alors il
faut quand même dire aux gens peut-être
la vérité aussi parce qu'un jour j'ai un
pote qui m'a dit tu fais ça pour deux
heures c'est vrai que c'est les tarifs
qu'on prenne à peu près 3 4000 €, je dis
la vérité mais c'est vrai que non c'est
pas pour deux heures tu prends le train
ah tu as 3 heures de train tu arrives
là-bas
avec le patron de la boîte tu tortues
bien que j'ai dit à mon meilleur ami si
j'en ai marre je fais des bookings
quasiment un samedi sur deux je suis
crevé et me déco tu te rends compte
quand même que à chaque fois on a un
soir tu prends le mon salaire d'un mois
les gens connaissent je comprends pas en
fait de quoi les gens de vous faire
venir en boîte de nuit les gens
d'aller au contact des fans écouter
les choses extra comme ça
va venir dans cette boîte
du parking ça attire personne tu vois la
vérité vous pouvez danser vous devez
faire un show un truc il y a pas marqué
par contrat non non moi ce qui était
très drôle je vais quand même raconter
des anecdotes c'est que quand j'allais
que Jean-Michel c'était pendant TPMP et
ça a eu levé que le succès de TPMP
évidemment et
dans la remise de la boîte de nuit ici
sur les bouteilles de Perrier comme ça
on était là en général tu as un mec avec
la sécu qui a un gros chien qui est à
côté de toi il est 3h du mat il était un
micro qui dit ils sont chauds ils sont
chauds ils vont arriver début ils ont
joué nous on est là on est assis sur des
bouteilles de tes canettes de Perrier à
3h du mat [ __ ] mais qu'est-ce qui
branle et la tête mec qui passe une tête
et qui dit les gars je vous fais rentrer
sur les sardines la chanson de Patrick
Sébastien je vous fais rentrer sur les
sardines ce que vous aimez beaucoup qui
toi j'ai 3h du matin tu es top tu as
rien bu t'as 10 mots mais les gars et là
tu vois on arrive à 4
c'est à la fin j'en ai une visage pas
les sardines
en sortant de Secret Story après j'avais
arrêté quand j'étais en couple parce
qu'il supportait pas ça mais j'en ai
fait beaucoup et oui j'étais très très
bien payé j'ai été payé une fois jusqu'à
8000 euros
en sortant de Secret Story
ça va aller la lecture c'est une
plaisanterie c'est une plaisanterie
tu reviendras tu reviendras quand même
ouais c'est pas cette semaine
merci
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait des des
petites truc un peu extra je me dois
quand on est comme ça star de TF1 payer
non non en tout cas pas moi Jésus
quand j'étais chez TF1 j'ai fait
énormément énormément de d'émissions par
exemple on lançait une émission un prime
etc et comme on faisait partie de la
boîte on faisait partie du du voilà du
cheptel on y allait gratos
par série par numéro et
j'espère que nous nous touchons quand on
a commencé à cartonner dans femme de loi
et quand je dirais vraiment à la
renégociation des des salaires c'est à
dire en 2006 et donc fin 2006 donc ça a
duré quoi deux ans après c'est ça
n'avait rien à voir avec le salaire des
anciennes c'est à dire
en pesos
c'était combien allez par semaine je
pense qu'on était à quoi de 12
14000 euros la semaine la semaine donc
60000 euros par mois 60
000 euros par mois mais c'est pas une
animation
entre 100 et 150000 euros par épisode a
beaucoup plus nous on était on était
payé parce qu'on est passé aussi à du 52
minutes et on était payé je pense au
mieux on était payé
[Musique]
un peu plus de 100 000 pour 2 52 minutes
vous parlent jamais rien
de l'argent pour faire des ménages
3000 € en boîte de nuit
et ce que je fais en revanche est-ce
qu'on a fait avec Pascal de temps en
temps c'est d'animer des conférences ou
des débats ça a plein de gens l'ont fait
et des conseils
voilà j'en ai encore fait il y a pas
longtemps gratuit pour une association
pour le suicide des adolescents et
mairie de Paris avec un jour et c'était
totalement gratuit
pour les autres
très très bien parfait au dernier mot il
va changer Béné
vole maintenant je vais faire un
anniversaire de restaurant bénévolement
et sinon j'ai fait avec Jean-Michel
l'ouverture d'un falafel la semaine
prochaine à Boulogne gratos gratuites
c'est une fois avec Jean-Michel une fois
avec Gilles la foire de roman j'ai versé
des associations
oh là là mais c'est un bébé
[Applaudissements]